inicialmente eu gostaria de primeiro
gostaria de agradecer a toda a
espiritualidade amiga a todos os mais
velhos a todas as mais velhas que nos
orientaram e nos ajudaram a chegar até
aqui
nesse momento eu também gostaria de
contar uma história que ouvi de um
escritor chamado peter senge nessa
história é chamada de te vejo entre as
tribos do norte de natal na africa do
sul a saudação mais comum é equivalente
ao nosso popular oi é expressão só abona
literalmente significa te vejo sendo
membro da tribo você deveria responder
dizendo se conam que significa que estou
aqui a ordem da troca é importante
porque até você me ver eu não existo
é como se eu me ver você me fizesse
vestir e significado implícito na língua
faz parte da disposição de espírito que
nós chamamos de um boto uma disposição
de espírito que diz assim uma pessoa é
uma pessoa por causa de outras pessoas
esse ensinamento africano ele nos
transporta para um momento crucial da
nossa vida foi quando no teste do
pezinho nós tivemos um resultado do
diagnóstico da nossa filha
ela tinha uma doença chamada doença
falciforme é o susto inicial neste
momento quando nós olhamos aquele
resultado e procuramos saber com quem
nós iremos dialogar
esse diálogo pode decidir o primeiro com
a geneticista ela nos olhou e nos contou
tudo o que deveria ser em relação à
doença nos acalmamos mas ao mesmo tempo
vieram várias angústias como seria a
vida da nossa filha como seria o seu
crescimento o seu desenvolvimento
medo muito medo dúvidas muitas dúvidas
nós passamos meses em busca de
informações lendo todo tipo de manual
técnico acessando todo tipo de
informação
então saber cada vez mais sobre essa
doença e descobrimos falciforme forma de
foice ou de mello a uma doença que
provocava dores nas articulações
uma doença que levavam a suscetibilidade
maior para infecções pneumonia e outras
complicações
só que essas informações que nós
tínhamos
ela não condiziam com aquilo que nós
estávamos vendo a nossa filha que
crescia sorrindo mamando brincando e
mais ainda essas informações se chocavam
fortemente com nossos sonhos deverá
crescer sorrir a brincar com uma criança
como outra qualquer mas quando as
crianças começaram por volta dos oito
meses de vida oito meses
a doença falciforme chegou implacável
já com internamentos e dores muitas
dores
nesse tempo também uma outra questão
começou a fazer parte do nosso cotidiano
nós deveríamos ou não formar uma
associação de pessoas com doença
falciforme defendendo foi nossa
é uma profissional de saúde que nos
acompanhar o acompanhava
ela dizia que em alguns lugares que
tinham associação era sempre melhor
havia luta havia uma mudança no
prognóstico de vida das pessoas
nós levamos mais de um ano até tomarmos
a decisão de formar uma associação
até esse tempo não estavam muito
preocupados de cuidar da nossa filha mas
conseguimos o contato de alguns pais e
procuramos conversar com eles porque fiz
era um sonho era um sonho que nós não
podíamos ganhar sozinho nós precisamos
de outros sonhos pra poder continuar a
caminhada e isso nos lembra um outro
ensinamento africano que diz assim se
você quiser ir rápido vá só se você
quiser ir longe vá acompanhado
estávamos então em busca de outras
pessoas com outros sonhos para poder nos
ajudar nessa caminhada
mas sonhar com que e aí nós pensamos o
sonhar com uma vida melhor
conseguimos então o contato de outros
pais e chamamos para uma reunião na
quele grande grupo
os olhares eram extremamente sofridos
como eles perguntassem o que eu estou
fazendo aqui porque é que eu estou aqui
e foi nesse encontro de dores que nós
percebemos que nós tínhamos muito mais
dos nossos amores para poder transformar
as nossas vidas e aqueles pais nos
traziam outras informações como essa
baixa expectativa de vida
alguns pais diziam assim olha eu ouvi de
um profissional de saúde que meu filho
morrer com 7 ou com 14 ou com 21
até hoje eu não sei por que escolher um
número cabalístico 7 pra poder ilustrar
esse prognóstico
e perguntamos algumas coisas pra esse
pai e seus pais o que era a doença
falciforme pra vocês porque ela nos
incomodava tanto que medos nós tínhamos
e será que nós deveríamos nos unir em
uma associação para transformar essa
realidade nós deveríamos constituir um
processo que nós deveríamos chamar de
união união é essa que ganhou um nome
abade fao associação bahiana das pessoas
com doença falciforme
a associação essa que vem juntar pessoas
com a doença familiares amigos
profissionais de saúde com a missão de
lutar pelo direito de defesa das pessoas
por uma cidadania por uma saúde melhor
naquele momento talvez nem nós
soubéssemos que estamos traçando uma
importante mudança de rumo na nossas
próprias trajetórias
nós estávamos começando a dizer que a
questão das pessoas com doença
falciforme não deveria ser uma questão
somente das suas famílias mas deveria
ter também de toda a sociedade mas ver
se era um sonho que não se estabelecia
apenas de uma fala sozinho era um
diálogo que não era somente sobre a
criação de uma associação
então nós podemos dizer que nossa
conversa hoje também não é sobre isso
nós não estamos somente para falar sobre
como criamos um sucesso
mas falar como as pessoas pessoas
simples pessoas que nunca tinham se
pronunciado dentro de um processo
político conseguiram transformar suas
dores
numa ação de amor de ser viva no ação de
amor transformadora da sua própria
realidade
eles começaram a pensar nós poderíamos
ser sujeito da nossa própria história
tirar a doença do centro da atenção e
colocar a pessoa com doença falciforme
no centro do cuidado era mais do que um
mero jogo de palavras
era uma mudança na perspectiva da
construção da política pública de saúde
traduzia uma alteração no pensar e na
construção dessas próprias políticas e
aí uma frase nos marcou muito era a
frase do movimento de pessoas com
deficiência que deverá assim nada sobre
nós sem nós e isso nos marcou muito
porque algumas pessoas nos viam como um
dos pais daquele filme o óleo de lorenzo
seja devem ter assistido e nós dizíamos
que não os pais do filme o óleo de
lorenzo ele descobrir um composto que
modificou a qualidade de vida do seu
filho
mas nós tínhamos redescoberto um outro
composto que tinha modificado a nossa
vida que era a esperança de sonhar ou
esperançar esperanza e cyberbullying
criado por paulo freire não significa
esperar esperançar é não desistir
esperanza é levar adiante esperanza é se
juntar com outros para fazer de uma
forma diferente e aí nós compreendíamos
que a nossa participação enquanto a
associação incomodava mas ela também era
a mola propulsora e transformadora da
realidade à qual não estavam devendo
essa participação que não se limitava
somente ao nosso olhar porque nós
descobrimos que em outros lugares essas
outras associações podiam vir junto
conosco e nós formamos afirma a fao a
formação da federação
nacional das associações de pessoas com
doença falciforme consolidou um outro
pensar e do agir local mas agora
precisamos agir e pensar de forma global
porque o sistema de saúde no brasil ele
pensa estrutura na atenção à saúde nos
municípios estados e governo federal
então nós precisamos ser mais muito mais
estávamos agora então falando de
protagonismo das pessoas com doença
falciforme não só na construção de
políticas mas nós participamos
efetivamente na construção de manuais na
capacitação de profissionais na
construção da política nacional de saúde
da população negra mas mexer com esses
aspectos nos trouxe uma outra questão
que os manuais não abordavam porque
mesmo a doença a doença falciforme e
mesmo sendo a doença genética de maior
prevalência no brasil com um caso a cada
mil nascimentos
e aqui na bahia um caso a cada 650
nascimentos havia demorado quase um
século para constituir uma política
pública porque explico o primeiro relato
científico amplo sobre a doença
falciforme
fidel em 1910 nos estados unidos
enquanto que a primeira política pública
para atender as pessoas com a doença só
aconteceu em 2005 95 anos depois revela
se aí uma outra dinâmica social e
extremamente séria que o impacto do
racismo na saúde a doença falciforme é
uma doença prevalente na população negra
não exclusiva prevalente e os estudos
demonstram que o seu surgimento cedeu no
continente africano parte da ásia e
parte da europa ea entrada do jem da
doença falciforme no novo mundo vai
findar através do tráfico das pessoas
que foram roubadas seqüestrados no
continente africano
uma médica lauren smith no estudo sobre
qualidade de vida e equidade ela explica
bem esse fato
ela nos diz que a questão da raça tem
sido intrinsecamente ligada com a doença
falciforme
desde sua descrição apesar de ser pouco
confortável contemplar isso diz a laura
em nós precisamos admitir que consciente
ou inconscientemente a prevalência da
doença falciforme na população negra
afete os recursos disponíveis não apenas
para pesquisa mas também para o
tratamento médico dessas pessoas
estávamos então diante de uma situação
que ia para além do plano biológico para
além de falar de uma doença de suas
sequelas
estamos diante de uma exclusão provocada
pelo racismo que estava espraiado na
sociedade dificultando o acesso o
conhecimento a informação ea
disponibilização da atenção à saúde
como diz a laura em 20
não é fácil não é confortável falar
sobre racismo mas quando nós imaginamos
que vamos entrar nos sistemas de busca
seja google seja qualquer outro e lá nós
vamos encontrar mais de 400 mil páginas
falando sobre a doença falciforme e que
hoje 2018 108 anos depois do primeiro
relato científico profissionais de saúde
estudantes de medicina e enfermagem
outro não conhecem a doença
nós temos aí a certeza do racismo
institucional operando para manter a
doença falciforme na invisibilidade a
incidência da doença falciforme a sua
gravidade
deveria ser considerada nesse país como
um problema de saúde pública mas
imaginem demorou quase um século para se
ter essa assistência
não sei se vocês percebem mas nós
passamos da dimensão familiar para a
dimensão local para uma dimensão global
isso tudo porque nós ousamos ter um
sonho e de repente nós percebemos que o
nosso sonho ele se juntava muito com as
palavras de martin luther king que vivia
eu tenho um sonho
nós tínhamos um sonho e nós vamos lutar
para realizar esse sonho e de repente
nós vimos que o nosso sonho era também o
sonho de zumbi
era o sonho de andar a é o sonho de
elétrons ali sabia do nascimento
mariele franco diz modo katendê nós
vimos que esse sonho era o sonho do
movimento negro brasileiro que dizia
nossos passos vêm de longe o sonho de
uma sociedade mais igualitária e justa
passa também pelo acesso à saúde passa
pela qualidade da assistência ea
vivência com a doença falciforme nos
trouxe saber porque se hoje nós temos
dificuldades e falta medicamentos em
falta assistência se nós temos diversos
problemas nós olhamos para trás e vemos
que há algum tempo nós não tínhamos
quase nada e aí nós lembramos de um
outro filme matrix mais precisamente o
terceiro revolution na cena final depois
que acontece toda luta entre homens e
máquinas máquinas
o ajudante de oráculo aquela que tudo
sabe e tudo vê no filme e que não por
acaso é uma mulher negra o ajudante
chega para ele e diz assim a senhora
sabia que ia terminar assim ela diz não
eu não sabia mas eu acreditava acreditar
sempre foi a nossa crença acreditar
sempre foi a nossa esperança ea nossa
vida acreditar que rima com esperançar
por isso nós percebemos que nós não
deveríamos ganhar sozinho nós precisamos
de mais pessoas
ainda mais pra sonhar com nosco e nós
realizamos uma grande campanha mundial
com uma frase eu amo uma pessoa com
doença falciforme em quatro línguas
francês inglês espanhol e português
convidamos as pessoas vai fazer um
cartaz e publicar
nós recebemos mais de 2500 fotos de mais
de 20 países
nem falamos de amor numa situação
extremamente difícil para todos e todas
que pensam numa sociedade melhor
uma sociedade melhor que nos pede que
nós possamos nos ver e que nós possamos
dizer ao outro ea outra só abona que nós
possamos ouvir do outro da outra
psicóloga e que naldo os enxergamos nós
podemos reconhecer que as nossas
diferenças não nos afastam muito pelo
contrário
exatamente são a nossa diferença aquino
junto e nos fortalecem e que nos faz ver
que nós podemos lutar por uma sociedade
ferracista fim machismo e homofobia esse
é o nosso sonho é o nosso convite vem a
sonhar com nosco porque esse sonho é
para além do que se vê do que se sente
do que se vive
eu sou porque nós somos ninguém solta
mão de ninguém um vulto
[Aplausos]